hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play lusus
okay you guys have told me many great
tips because you're all awesome in a
little offense but you guys have told me
many great tips like where the other
piece locations are and how to get past
this little Poochie here so what we do
is we take the ash and we throw it in
its face or that's what you guys say I
don't know how this is gonna work out
because it doesn't seem a good idea to
let it get close enough to use the ash
on it boy at the same time I'm like oh
what's the harm what could happen what's
the harm why not give it a try man wanna
give it a try hey pootie ah night doggy
get away get away birthday get away
you're not very fast day yeah hey Doug
what do I owe that Oh ash no that did
not work okay the ash was a terrible
idea
you guys led me astray just cuz you
wanted to see me die again so I don't
appreciate Oh appreciate know that it's
not very fast I'm just gonna run past it
because you guys also told me that I was
right that there I read that there was
body in the cemetery but it's not in the
cemetery it was outside of the cemetery
which I misread or did not read or was
going by too quickly because I skipped
through notes too quickly and I don't
know why so I'm just gonna run past the
wolf it's not very fast so whatever haha
I'm just gonna do the old Juke on it and
do a 360 spin go in for a field goal
touchdown and then score a goal unit
basket chimera PI J one one one ah go I
dog it night doggy hahahaha
Kyodai how'd you get pod my barrel
barrel anyone remember that anyway that
is an old quote from a long time ago ah
he's right on my heels he'd run off my
heels I'm hoping because he stopped
chasing me when I went up the log maybe
he'll stop chasing me when I get to the
cemetery unlikely as that maybe it's
possible maybe he can't cross his bridge
go i poach e go away it's gonna get me
it's gotta get me
oh he's still there I thought for a
second sounds like he's fading though is
he getting farther away is my amazing
running speed finally getting away from
this wolf probably not if that's just
the NPC threat they added not very happy
fun times okay now I just got to
remember where the cemetery was I have
no idea I have no idea it's not up that
way that's a way to the epic
hako quiet oh yay booty left me alone I
think it's up to the right here
cemeteries up this way I believe ha ha
ha
finally alright that's all you got to do
is run away from the booty ok so huh
what hell no you're not gonna be able to
know what up where do you come from
what the hell booty go to grave die ha
ha that's not fair what the hell I'm
going on what's going on what's going on
I can't I'm not gonna be able to what is
going on gonna be another Walter ah come
on
was that insane wolf or another wolf I
don't know well this is stupid
how am I gonna get away with yeah I'm
gonna lose him in the town I'm gonna go
all the way through town then cut around
in a big circle well this is just dumb
get away from me Bujji I don't want any
I don't want to tangle with you I don't
like doggies no I like doggies I don't
like wolves
I don't see anyone like wolves you know
ever made doggy
you can't navigate this terrain like me
a human can did he stop following me cuz
I went into town that music stop but
then I don't trust that because it
stopped before and then all sudden hey
were you trying to go to the cemetery
I'm just gonna follow you until I butt
off your wrinkles
anybody Wolfie Wolfie
ha ha I have lost you ha ha I'm gonna
actually get my shovel out and ready huh
just in case I have to make a running
grab for this dead body I also got to go
back to the epithelia because you guys
told me there was another stone part
somewhere in there so I'm gonna go get
that one there a total of five I think
either way I need to get from the body a
key from the body which should leads to
the mayor's house that was mentioned in
the book is that a wolfy cat a wolfy is
that a wolfy okay looking for a dirt the
converter the converter looking for dirt
dirt dirt got to be quick that dirt no
that's not dirt where's the dirt dirt
dirty dirt where's the dirt AHA found
you dirt you can't escape from me do
cover for you also
I gotta check the cemetery again because
there might be a stone piece in here
that I'm missing not exactly sure so I
will check undone ah grab a key key key
please
key was it a pocket oh no not a gun ah
I'll lose you in town again don't even
try it I have to be careful I already
know there was a wolf I already know
actually let me check the outskirts of
the cemetery again and then on yeah well
no well no no no no don't get stuck on
terrain no time got a navigate he ain't
gonna get me he's slow I'll lose him in
town again just in case I don't see
anything I'm not gonna I'm just gonna
try to spot it and then I'm gonna run
away don't you just run just run you
can't catch you he can't catch me I'm
the gingerbread markiplier ain't gonna
give me Yangon get me actually I got the
key to the mayor's house so let me go up
straight to the mayor's house
I can probably I can brawl yeah I can
probably I'll he's right behind me I'm
not even gonna be oh my god I'm not
gonna be able to switch to the key
uh-huh all right I'm making a judgement
call I'm gonna lose them in
town I'm gonna lose him in town screw it
screw it I'm losing him in town cuz I'm
not gonna be able to whip out my key and
then Jimmy the lock and then get in
there and I'm probably gonna lose him
there anyway just gonna lose him in town
to pro he's are quieted down again y
know I hear you I'm not turning around
turn around would be a death trap that's
crap I hear you oh no I forgot about the
other wolf that I lost in town before
okay I got me ah I'm a big whiny baby Oh
with that uh what - Pro for you put that
down get that key alright yeah - awesome
I'm actually gonna take a shortcut up
this road here cuz I know actually no no
I'm not no I'm not cuz I led to a hill I
can't go that way
wolf a wolf a is you gone you better be
gone
you son of a [ __ ] I do not like you I
do not want to mess with you but as far
as NPC threats go that's not it
particularly scary it's like like I'm in
case you guys didn't write in the
comments of what I was referencing
before that was penumbra when penumbra
the only threats in penumbra the
original were the doggies and they
weren't particularly scary I mean they
could bash down doors if they really
tried to but I mean they weren't
particularly scary alright anyway yeah
oh no I thought this won't do well then
what the [ __ ] is is key for you guys
lied to me you got to be joking me
you cured you be joking me can I get
open with the with the screwdriver
uh-huh all right
oh well I'm not gonna go through town
and just try to rim things so I'll be
right back I'm gonna try to figure this
out so
aha
okay I'm back guys ha ha ha ha when you
said a gate I assume that was that other
gate but I forgot that there was another
gate up here I remember running into
this a long time ago not being able to
do anything so I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
quickly scan the grounds for dirt piles
any dirt piles here piles of dirt I call
it cup of dirt
it's a cup with dirt in it I call it cup
of dirt just give me an F and move on
okay ha hello blue tires I can might be
able to use that cut something like a
lock off of a gate make me Oh No so this
is supposedly the mayor's house can I
climb up there
I can ha ha wait what was the point of
this I see a window up there oh oh oh oh
super genius oh I am so smart I'm so
smart I'm so smart oh hello
oh boy huh huh what did I just get
myself into oh my oh my haunted house
time apparently
hello saving nightmare oh look at that
little guy okay no lights hello is
somebody in here close a condo let I
cannot light didn't I have a lighter at
some point no that was a different game
anything anything anything nothing
anything anything anything anything a
heavy looking iron can I use that to
bash on monsters face n-no behind the
painting a woman with a serpent coiled
around her there is also a man lying
like he's asleep or dead I'm
to go with dead I mean the lights are
not working in here not a good sign
smash your [ __ ] balcony well this is
nice but not very big that's what she
said
anybody hello I'm just little man
nice painting trying to wander around
your house did I find matches did I just
find matches liquid oh for a lighter oh
cool
does that mean I'll get a lighter I
would sure love a lighter they're plenty
of candles here that would just waiting
to be lit unless I'm gonna use that for
like a fuel to light a bomb or some sort
oh there's light down here
good it was getting kind of disturbing
up there there's a light coming from
under that door that's not a good sign I
know this Universal bad signs in gaming
seriously what time period is this
because it seems like all of these
houses are out of some small Russian
town in like the 1920s it's ridiculous I
don't even know where this is located I
mean if this is supposed to be a mansion
hello oh that's the front door oh okay
nothing them no one flocked I need to
find a way to pick the lock how about a
screwdriver
I don't think this will work how about
the pliers it's locked I need a [ __ ]
know how about the shovel
no okay alrighty then so I need to find
some sort of plier type device maybe in
here I've checked every other room quite
thoroughly I might add no no well what
the hell I looks like I'm gonna be stuck
here for a while okay be right back when
I figure this out something smells nice
here
hi some things well die here what smells
nice there's a nice smell in the
backyard Liz this it's mint why do I
need me
and why why and I'm gonna check for
piles of dirt cuz I love me some
positive there where's the dirt pile why
does he where's the dirt pile where's
the dirt pile set a dirt pile it looks
like it might be a dirt pile no it's not
dirt pile where's the dirt pile where's
this won't do
wait a minute why am i shoveling the
bike wait what's with the bike it's a
bicycle can I use it to ride out of this
stupid town no you just need to fix it
up just need to fix it up use the mint
on it burn it Alai heave use the ashes
on it use the pliers on it what did I
get two pieces of wire why why I'm
having a say anything I'm not even gonna
sexting no no way I need to bend them
first [ __ ] how do I been okay I need to
find a way to bend them what nerve Oh
use the pliers on them I don't know just
bend them use this iron use something
bend them Bend oh they're tiny pieces of
wire why in the world would I not be
able to bend them
what could possibly be used to bend them
a rock the pliers would work they would
my brain is not working my brain is
completely frazzled is it something here
is it something there what
what could possibly I'm gonna I'm gonna
there anyplace I'm trying to think very
clearly is there any place that had
something that I could bend them there
must have been something somewhere that
could have bent them that's the only
thing I'm trying to follow the logic of
this game if I can't bend them by hand
then it's going to say then it's
obviously saying that I need to bend
them with something with a lot of
strength it was the thing by the river
there was nothing down by the river
there was a axe at some point but I lost
the axe there's a single generator room
there was a blacksmith house there
anything in the blacksmith house like an
anvil or a hammer that's the only clue I
have to go on so let's go to the
blacksmith's Klaus
I don't think where was that vise the
vise was that in the blacksmith house
well where's the blacksmith where's the
blacksmith ha ha ha ha he wants to black
music where's the blacksmith Oh God
what the hell is that I will murder your
face what the hell are you doing do not
come between me and the boy I'm gonna
lose you cuz you're fast ain't you
where's the black I'll kill him
he's been tormenting our blacksmith too
much ah where's the blacksmith what is
this is that even supposed to be scary
hi hi you want some mint
I got mint for no reason where'd you go
where'd you go where'd you go huh
where'd you go huh oh hello you got
stuck on a corner well come on come on
what you've got huh huh yeah wha no
I probably should let him the other way
around though village I'm gonna go I'm
pretty sure I'm almost 100% sure that
that Vice is in the blacksmith house I
don't know why they didn't click for me
immediately but I'm trying to keep track
of a lot of things in this game so
excuse me uh please pardon me if I lose
logic ah ah screw you
what are you done get out here you can't
make it around corners obviously hello
you come here hi hi
No come here hey over here over here
douche douche no oh no oh whoa hey what
huh do I believe it all right there we
go oh no you don't want to tangle with
me I understand I'm too proud for you
what are you doing you douche re
whatever I'm going around this is what
the wolf did because it wasn't looking
at the wolf he better let me out of here
I don't even know where the hell he's
going this is just regard
damned Achilles hello are you here now
where are you where are you you're there
what are you doing are you is that gonna
kill me you really think that that's
gonna kill me a torch I will I will
elbow drop you with my shovel Oh term I
Oh Bend bye shovel into an elbow just to
drop it on you hi I think he's a little
bit faster than me so I don't know if
I'm gonna get to the blacksmith I was
the blacksmith you cannot stop me I am
too powerful I'll go John oh hi where
you going now straight up the hill
well that's cheating where's the
blacksmith here's a black man dirty okay
and it banned it
they're so tiny they're so tiny use the
pliers cut well our guy can't run anyway
so in all honesty is this even
surprising is this even a little bit
surprising that he can't bend those tiny
itty bitty wires by himself he even had
pliers with him and he used the pliers I
don't get this game but I am still
playing it I do not understand this game
I don't understand the choices that it
makes none of it makes any sense to me
but that's all irrelevant because here
we go you know here we go I've got me a
handful of mint a pocketful of ashes and
a heart full of Dreams Bing ah where's
my dreams where's my hope where is any
of it
where's anything-anything where's my
myrin where's my mind gone I don't know
all right okay you know I'm just looking
at this thing maybe I can can I mash up
the mint no I would have been I would
have been so happy if I could have done
that and somehow I'm an amazing lockpick
oh I'm gonna get in this and I've done
it I've done it
let's do not work like I expected hello
among the numerous writings by Greek
mathematician engineer hair on I will
read this in the off time because I'm
gonna end this I will read this
off-camera you guys can read through it
if you want if you want to pause it here
but pause quickly because I'm just
flipping through right there it's some
sort of device I will read this I will
read all of it off camera I just want
waste you guys time now and
okay so anyway there's a lot of books
here I don't particularly care about
right now we'll get them later later
later later later later later later
later later later okay
another book oh my god later later later
later we'll read later where this is
Typho yes
the guy that they were talking about
before that they were gonna summon gonna
get all this later later okay
that would have been helpful at the
beginning of the frickin game why do you
give me a map now that I know where
everything is there aren't even marking
for like dig sites is there any reason
why I couldn't have gotten that or been
given that at the beginning of the game
nope well okey-dokey then
I'm just gonna find everything in here
and key well don't know oh no no you
don't oh no oh no there we go
key save and a note let's read this note
we're pleased to inform you that finally
got the man who thought he could arrest
our avert our plans he had a key and a
map on him we interrogated him but he
didn't tell us anything we know that the
key opens the entrance to the temple
area so we suspect that he has hidden
the sacred item in the temple we still
haven't found a way to enter it as it is
securely sealed and above the door
there's a sign that says none
uninitiated shall enter we would also
like to inform you that the catalyst is
here however it seems that Isle
disagrees that M disagrees with the
procedure and has gone rogue we will
make sure that he doesn't ruin our plans
and also that the item stays in the
temple oh come on I've read all that by
hand okay never mind
end of book okay we're done here for now
hmm all right anyway so okay thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for videos it I've done and
as always I will see
Oh
right
Oh
blood
Oh
here are